uh this is ee 380
stanford's computer systems
computer systems colloquium uh the
date is uh june 17
2021 our speaker today is carl hewitt
he's going to speak about preventing
successful cyber security attacks
using strongly typed actors
carl is an emeritus professor from
mit and a long-standing
researcher in areas of security
and programming language design and
[Music]
complex distributed systems carl
the screen is yours and uh go ahead
thank you thank you very much dennis
i'm here with my colleague and friend
john perry
who will be the discussant for this
colloquium
and we'll see if john and i are still
friends at the end of the colloquium
[Laughter]
i have high hopes and you'll find that
we got plenty we got a few
bad jokes uh in this colloquium and that
was just the first one
so let us proceed through here i will
now share my screen
which will hopefully work and this is
screen two and hopefully this will put
up the title slide
okay cool excellent okay
so here we are and and dennis said what
the tie what the title is it's
preventing successful cyber attacks
using strongly typed actors we can't
prevent the cyber attacks but we can in
many cases prevent them from being
successful
and so uh here's me and there's my blog
and i just want to mention
right off the bat
that
there's a article that you can get
associated has the content of this talk
with the same title and if
if you can't remember that link you just
go to my blog which is professor
hewitt.blogspot.com and there's a link
for it there
so the greats the strategy of this
colloquium
is to try to stay out of the weeds to
try to give an overview of what's going
on
so i'll put up some slides that have a
little bit too much detail in them but
don't fear
we won't actually go through the details
of these slides but i just say what the
meaning is and the
expectation is that you can go to
the article if you really want to dig in
and we have a way of keeping ourselves
honest
namely the cyber attackers will keep us
if our proofs are no good they will
exploit the
hell out of us so we have a strong
incentive to get that right
so let us proceed
and what we're faced with is great power
strategic cyber attacks
what does all this mean these are
attacks that that
that are launched by great powers of
which there are only a few
in this world the united states is one
of them
and a strategic cyber attack is much
more serious than these point
ransomware attacks in a strategic cyber
attack
the attacker is aiming to take down a
country's
economy and keeping it down
indefinitely using reiterated cyber
attacks
millions of people could die and the
question on the table
is how to prevent disaster
so here's the discussion plan for
uh for this colloquium i'll talk about
the inadequacies the laminar calculus
and the turing machine
which are the uh which are the current
orthodoxy
how something an abstraction called
actors has been
around for a while that can overcome
these inadequacies
talk about strong types for higher order
propositions that's
jargon we'll come to later
and talk about how we're going to
prevent some next generation cyber
attacks against things called
i'm unprovable i'm not provably
consistent my theorems are innumerable
these are things that currently exist in
our encyclopedias
and exist in our textbooks
that are in need of update and until
they're updated
we are vulnerable to these cyber attacks
and then i'll talk
at the end about something called
project liftoff
which is an apollo scale 10-year project
that it takes for us to prevent
these kinds of devastating cyber attacks
so what we're doing here is we're
shoring up the foundations of computing
and there's a a a quotation by alexander
mcqueen who's a famous
artist and designer he's done some
magnificent work recommend you look him
up
his quotation is that's what i'm here
for
to demolish the old rules but to keep
to the tradition and here we have the
leaner tower of pizza
in the background right and so that is
what we're about
so we'll now move to the first
discussion session
john well first of all it's
great that you're taking on these big
targets like in
russia and china and so forth but how
about how about these
uh uh ransomware things would your
theory will your
agent excuse me actor program
deal successfully with those two oh
absolutely
yeah i mean if because those guys are
amateurs
actually launching pin printed
pin prick attacks when a great power
goes after an economy
they have you know upwards of 10 000
highly trained attackers manning and
coordinating the attacks so
so right these these these are pip
squeak attacks in the grand scheme of
things
against what we're truly up against
which is the strategic cyber attack but
excellent question
well it's it's good to hear that because
i lose a lot of sleep thinking some
ransomware guy is going to take me and
keep me from getting to all my
philosophy papers and charge me 10 or 15
ransom
to get them back well you're probably
not much danger but lots of small
businesses are now
now uh biden has now warned putin that
he that that that he's not going to
tolerate this against you know certain
significant targets in the united states
and the united states
will retaliate if he does we'll see how
that goes
but retaliation really isn't that is not
an adequate solution to the problem of
strategic
uh cyber attacks because you still go
down
even if you can take the other guy down
and
in attacks against lesser powers like if
somebody should take down
the whole economy of ukraine
it's unlikely that the united states
would want to do a full bar
strategic cyber attack against whoever
did the attack against the ukraine
and the same is true of taiwan if
somebody should take down the whole
economy of taiwan
it may well be that the united states
doesn't want to do a strategic
cyber attack to try to take down whoever
attacked taiwan
so so here we go
so i'd like to talk about the lambda
calculus and the turing machine now
these were
these were terrific achievements one by
alonzo
church was a great computer scientist
and everybody knows about
alan turing but here is
their model of computation an isolated
human is provided with means to
incrementally obtain
paper and pencils without limit no
budget
the computation began providing the
human with paper input that includes
particular instructions how to carry out
the computation
no further input or output is allowed
the human is not allowed any outside
computation
can be outside communication during the
and if the human finishes the
instructions then a single
output of on paper occurs and the
computation
terminates voila
sounded good to me when i was an
undergraduate
yes but it is a little bit solipsistic
well miss fleming had a better idea
so she said women who have taken up
any branch of science need not be
discouraged
even if others refuse to give credit to
their work
labor honestly and consciousness
consciously and
steadily then must yield recognition and
success
must crown your efforts in the end i
garble that but that's okay
uh fleming got it right so what was her
idea
what was her idea was this kind of
computing
right you have an information center we
got your architects
your programmers and your domain experts
and at that time they were all
women running the information center
they pretty much did it there was a
senior guy in charge
but miss fleming and her crew here
did the work conceived the work
organized the work
and this is a different notion of
computing
than what alonzo church and alan turing
came up with
and a little bit later
they started doing simulations in world
war ii they were losing too many ships
to the u-boats
so they wanted to know why and they
started doing simulations these
simulations were run by
wrens which were which were female
naval officers right and here they are
in the midst of running a simulation
and they brought the the naval captains
in and put them in there and ran the
simulation
in order to teach them how to properly
hunt german submarines
and the wrens many of the wrens knew
more about it than the naval commanders
but the naval commanders that they did
some simulations
learned went back out to sea and were
much more successful
at hunting down german submarines
this is also carl just a quick point it
looks like the rings can talk to each
other
it looks like they could enlist each
other's help but they found something
difficult so so is your whole idea to
get us back to where we were with wrens
absolutely the wrens had a terrific idea
for computation but they got
no recognition the wrens were never
officially recognized after the war
okay so this is a different notion of
computation
the women had a better idea and this i
think this shows the danger of lack of
diversity in your organization
you don't do it just to be nice to x y
or z or because the government has a
regulation the reason you do it
is you can run a better organization if
you have diversity and you can recruit
from all parts of the world
and bring all the good ideas in as
opposed to just restricting it
to white anglo-saxon men
so so if students want to know more
about the reigns there's a good tv
series
uh it would be nice if i knew the name
but i don't but
but they're all clever and they can find
it about the rans
uh in uh world war ii and the
contribution
and also there's an excellent book about
it that's referenced in the article that
i gave a link to
at the beginning of this video
so that was our discussion
let me add one more thing yeah you said
that alonzo church was a computer
scientist not quite right
uh alonzo church and i were colleagues
at ucla
in the philosophy department true too
but he's not he's an honorary computer
scientist and one of the founders of
he did well when when we when we started
csli
i invited uh uh alonzo church to give a
talk
great and john john excellent he picked
him up at the airport and
and church said tell me about the center
what do you what do you deal with me
says well uh logic but
also a computer science and
church of computer science i don't know
quite what that is
but i had a student once alan turing who
i guess was pretty good at it
that's right there we go he was indeed
he uh alan turing was was alonzo
church's phd student at princeton
okay so yeah we we we we we go all the
way back to lady lovelace he's one of
the first programmers
he called a computer scientist either
but but eventually you're going to tell
me that church was wrong about something
and
i lose a lot of sleep over accepting
that idea
okay well i wouldn't say he was wrong
i'm just saying science
moves on we move from kepler
to galileo to newton to einstein
to quantum mechanics it moves on
but we build on what was there before so
let's take a look at that
well we are in a position where there
are many practical
applications that cannot be implemented
using the lambda calculus or
equivalently a turing machine so let's
have a very
simple example namely we have a train
controller we're doing train control we
have the people
the people talk to the train controller
the train controller talks to the engine
controller
the engine controller talks to the
engine the train controller talks to the
door controller and the door controller
talks to the door so that's our
application
cannot be done using the lambda calculus
so what does the train controller do
well the train controller gets over the
left hand side here it gets a closed
message a close request an open request
a stop request or a move request
and there are a whole bunch of there's a
whole bunch of weeds on this slide
details about what it does when it
receives each one of those kinds of
requests
the important thing is that these
requests can come in any time
and then they're processed one at a time
by the train controller
but the train controller has to keep
alert because the trained comp
controller doesn't want to be quote
asleep at the switch
another bad joke
so while the train controller
is processing a request okay
and it's got an outstanding message to
the engine controller that might take
the engine controller a long time to get
back to the train controller
so the train controller wants to be able
to to also be responding to things from
the door controller
while it has an outstanding request to
the engine controller
this is known as concurrency
where things can be acting concurrently
something that
never happens in the lambda calculus and
it never happens
in a turing machine and that is the real
difference
that our friends the women brought to us
with the with their models of
computation
namely at the harvard observatory and
the simulations that were run by the
wrens
so the net result is that we have a
little program here
for the train controller
the yellow thing is it's region of
mutual exclusion that's the way you
control the concurrency
you only allow one activity into the
region of mutual exclusion at a time
that's how you maintain your
your sanity that's how you don't have
variable races where you that you're
stomping all over each other
but this region of mutual exclusion has
holes in it
and the reason that it has a hole is it
needs to give up the region of
mutual exclusion and later reacquire
the region of mutual exclusion and there
are all sorts of new
programming languages out like out there
like there's airline
actors there's aca actors
there's and now they're swift actors
from apple
that all have to deal with this uh hole
in the region of mutual exclusion issue
so that is the basic kind of thing it's
it's the thing that
that was left out of the
turret church turing conception of
computation
is concurrency and it makes these actors
inherently more powerful
so what do you think john
you know i i like it i feel much safer
getting on train since
uh at least i will when they've all
adopted the
the actors theory and you say
apple's newest uh what what do they call
their newest swift swift actors
yes they have adopted they have doctor
i've gotten adopted the actor
abstract so so you're you're you're
gonna you're gonna get paid every time
they use it you're gonna be i wish i got
a royalty but i did the work too
far too long ago but who knows
there may be some future opportunities
for consulting or speaking or something
we'll see
well they ought to give you a big grant
there we go
okay so now
our great hero in days of yore is
somebody named
richard dedicate who is a terrific
mathematician and
john knows about him it's kind of
contemporary fraga
john's an absolute expert on fraga
written books about frank and fraga was
also
a notable pioneer it invented some of
our notations some of which is shown
here
like these upside down a's please don't
faint
[Laughter]
yeah so if you if you go from fragra
to church uh to church is lambda
calculus to lisp you've got
a pretty steady
series of uh influences from fraga
absolutely correct right lisp is the
last thing about computer science
i understood it all now this didn't have
any concurrency john didn't understand i
knew john mccarthy well john mccarthy
was a terrific computer scientist
but he didn't know anything about
concurrency
that's why it was hard to get him to
stop talking
i don't know about that he's not he's
not the worst computer scientist in that
respect but anyway
so i'm not going to go into all the
weeds here i'm not going to explain the
upside down a's and we don't even have
any backward ease
i spared you that right but what this
says is if you've got a system right
and you'd like to prove something about
all the events in this system
the way you do that is you show that
that whatever predicate p
that you want to prove for for all the
events in the system show that it
holds for all the events that come in
from the outside
and if it holds for some event in the
system
then it holds from er for every event
that immediately
follows from that event right
and if you have those two prerequisites
then you helped have succeeded improving
by a
induction that the predicate piece holds
for every event
on the system now this should remind you
of dedicans axiom for the natural
numbers where he showed well
you show that the predicate p is true of
zero
and if you can show that if it's true of
i then it's true of i plus 1
then it's true of every natural number
this is the analog
in concurrency and we can put this
to practical use
because there's an important safety
consideration in the operation
of the train namely you never
be you won't never want to have the the
train moving while the doors are open
that is just unsafe
so we'd like to prove that safety
property
for our implementation right and it's an
inductive proof
and here's the way the proof goes this
is again is our train controller program
and it's what we prove here is the train
controller
okay in its recording it records in its
variable moving whether
it's moving is tr is true or false and
is open the door is open
is true or false and
what we prove is the train controller is
never
in an inconsistent state
does that mean that the train is never
moving with the doors open
of course not that's the train
this is the train controller
but at least we can show that the train
controller tries to maintain
some kind of sanity over its situation
and it's pretty easy to prove that the
train controller has a safety proof
but there's much more than that to
proving that a train is safe believe me
because the train controller you know is
talking to the door controller and it's
talking to the engine controller
but the engine controller doesn't really
know whether the train is moving or not
it only knows what it's told the engine
right
and if there's a defect actual in the
engine
or s says the our gear is slipped and
the train can be moving and the engine
controller knows nothing
same thing for the door controller it's
got its switches its latches on the
doors right
but if an outside video camera sees that
the door is open then the door is open
even though the door controller thinks
it's closed
so that's the nature of proofs and the
real world
so what do you think john so
uh in in terms of wren's this is a
your idea i mean this yellow area is uh
one of the rain says okay i've completed
uh this little bit of of our program i'm
gonna put in the box
nobody interfere with it until i get it
back out again
is that kind of the idea that's the kind
of the idea is the region of niche
exclusions
while they're doing the simulation the
ren's are running around
moving uh ships on the floor right
uh with blue lines that are invisible to
the naval captains that are looking in
like
they can't see the little blue line so
there's some things that are hidden from
the neighborhood captains the rims are
uh talking amongst themselves and
signals among themselves and then they
say okay
now we'll go for the next simulation
step right
and meanwhile the capstans are sitting
there thinking about what they're going
to do about these
these submarines so that's the kind of
region of mutual exclusion
in a simulation where you have control
of what's going on as soon as you give
up the regional mutual exclusion
anything can come at you
a good question okay
so there was the discussion there and so
now we have a trick involved in this and
they're things called
things that computer science have
invented called types
that have a very long history so here we
have some examples of types
we use we use this script font for types
so we have n which is the type of
natural numbers that's a primitive type
and then we have uh
all all functions from t1 into t2 in
this example we have
halt halt is a predicate okay on an
expression
that says whether or not that
computation is going to halt
halt is not computable but it is a
mathematical function
on the other hand we have t1 arrow t
tube and that
is the type of partial computable
functions from t1 into t2
and factorial is our canonical example
there it's
it's it's it's it's it's of type you
know mapping a natural number into
a natural number and here we have
something
a little bit new called a proposition of
order i
and here in order to maintain the
consistency of foundations we need
orders on propositions and russell was
the first one to
do that to propose horizontal
propositions
and so so for example it says here that
two plus three equals five
is a proposition of order one and here
we have
dedicans oops sorry about that
here we have dedican's induction axiom
right here
and it says if p is a proposition of
order i
then we can show this and but the
induction axiom itself
is a proposition of order i plus one
we've gone up
one level in the hierarchy
and then we can put arbitrary
restrictions on types for example
suppose we have the type natural number
we can say n such
that for each i and n it must be the
case that there's some j
such that i equals j plus j and what
that means is we
define the type of even natural numbers
and there's even a backwards e in here
well good okay so
now the idea of these types is to make
it safe to have recursive
definitions recursive definitions are
fundamental to both mathematics and
programming so let's have
a little recursive definition
namely self-applicable procedures
so here we have a whole bunch of stuff
here where it's all strongly typed
and we're basically using an argument
that is due to alonso church and alan
turing
to show the undecidability of the
halting problem
and the halting problem is if you're
giving an expression
whether or not if you compute a way
whether or not it'll halt
and you do this using a great trick
you do a proof by counter dictionary if
somebody claims to have
a decider
that can decide computationally decide
whether or not expression halts
then you define an anti-decider that
uses the decider against itself
to obtain a contradiction
so the important part of this is to make
recursive definitions safe
which is something that turing and uh
and church didn't do
in their original proofs but it's
possible you know with a little bit of
uh ledger domain to do it which puts it
their proofs on a sound foundation
because we're about to see a whole bunch
of recursive definitions
which lead to cyber vulnerabilities
so it's important for the strong types
to prevent them
at the same time we want this proof to
go through
the uh the proof of the of the unsolved
undecidability halting problem needs to
go through that's a good proof
the other recursive definitions the bad
definitions we got to block them
we're about to see how we do that
so what do you think john well i just
point out that
1892 when he was getting started
he really had this view that if you have
a predicate
and you have a name the sentence that
consists of the name the predicate being
applied to the name made sense and had
to have a truth value
so is caesar a prime number or not
reagan didn't make that he didn't think
i was ridiculous he thought it was
irrelevant but if you're gonna have a
full system you had to give a truth
value to that
and so so russell saw
that if you're going to avoid russ i
mean
if you're going to avoid russell's
paradox which which was
uh to consider the property
uh uh shared by everything uh
that is a property of itself and then
consider
it you're gonna have to give up that
principle so that was step one
and uh but that alone doesn't solve it
i mean that makes it possible to
formulate these recursive definitions
in a way that will lead to a solution is
that the idea
yeah the idea is that we want to have a
complete freedom
in recursive definitions provided that
they type check
right they don't type check they're bad
and they don't make it into the
in in into the realm of the foundations
and that's really important because
we're about to see a deadly one
that must be blocked
but this one needs to go through and
this is
this is if you look into the details of
this quite sophisticated that the type
theory that's being used here because we
see we've defined
self-applicable to a procedure
parameterized by self-applicable so now
we're down in the weeds okay but they're
important weeds because this one has to
go through
whereas the one that giddle came up with
in 1934 must be blocked as we will see
so he thought he'd have a recursive
definition of something called i'm
unprovable i'm unprovable
it's defined to be you know not provable
i know i'm unprovable this little symbol
here means
not provable that's a perfectly good
recursive definition according to google
and the result is you have the
fundamental result i'm unprovable if and
only if
it's not provable that i'm unprovable
this thing is a disaster
turns out it's part of the current canon
it's in every undergraduate textbook
it's in all the encyclopedias
but it is a disaster
why because it leads to a
cyber attack it leads to an
inconsistency
in the foundations of mathematics and
i'm not going to go through all the
details
of the weeds here but if you're
interested
you can delve into it
so
why does so so that shows as a cyber
text we must not have it
and wittgenstein was the first one to
show
that i'm unprovable leads to
inconsistent foundations
and his reward was one to be ridiculed
and two to be ignored
okay so how do we do that
well once we put types on this i'm
unprovable it says the proposition of
order i
is defined to be not unpro uh not
provable i'm unprovable
okay it fails the type check
because this thing is a proposition of
order i plus 1 because
i'm unprovable is a proposition of i uh
order i
and i'm unprovable is a propositional
variable and you can't have
i'm unprovable as a proposition of order
i implies i'm unprovable is a
proposition of order i plus one
so i'm not going to try to convince you
of all this
stuff here right off the bat just tell
you that it's the case
and the important point here is that
nothing of importance in mathematics
depends on the existence of i'm
unprovable
we can do without it with no harm
no foul
but if we leave it in like the wikipedia
says you can or the encyclopedia say you
can
or the textbooks say you can then this
is the source
of a cyber attack that can take you out
so this is completely contrary to the
current orthodoxy
and that's where we are what do you
think john
well let me just uh review a little so
we got we got fraga
he slice work the grundy is that so
russell reddit said that's very
interesting but there's a contradiction
is the property of not being a property
of oneself
have that very property or said
theoretically does a set
of all sets that don't contain
themselves contain itself
and the answer is yeah right so so
russell
brought in the ethereum types and orders
to solve that
in the principle of mathematica that's
right
but then girdle says nope there's still
a contradiction
no you gotta live and say there's a
contradiction girl said that
completeness
not yet he said yeah yeah then you then
then you got
incompleteness uh which he proved by a
way of
contradiction and he prayed
really unfortunately he did epa proved
it by contradiction but his proof is
invalid because i'm unprovable does not
exactly exactly
you're saying but girdle didn't didn't
really do it because
he ignored russell's theory of types
that's that you ignored the orders on
propositions exactly
and now i made it more difficult because
the the orders on propositions never
actually physically appear in principia
mathematics
but they were there right when that was
planned out girl said well the title
doesn't quite reflect what i do
but still i did it uh that's
well he didn't do it for foundations you
see that was the whole thing about
principia mathematic it was the
foundations of mathematics
so you could girdle can retreat into a
tiny little theory
right of natural numbers that's of no
use whatsoever
and keep his i'm unprovable proposition
but then he has a theory that nobody
cares about the reason people
cared about his proof was it was that it
was
allegedly for principia mathematica
[Music]
but it ignored something that's
imprinted to mathematical and not
spelled out very clearly i must admit
mainly the whole idea of orders that's
right exactly yep
you're an actors are the next step in
this progression
uh elected theory theory is the next
step in this progression right okay so
then
goodell went further because
he thought because he had i'm unprovable
he thought that a theory a
foundational theory couldn't prove its
own
consistency so here we have some
formalism
about what it means to not be consistent
and we have this proposition i'm not
provably consistent
but this is wrong it turns out there's a
simple proof here
that a powerful foundational theory
can prove its consistency
however this
proof is not convincing so girdle is
technically wrong
okay a powerful theory of foundations
can prove its own consistency
but nobody thinks this proof although
technically correct
is convincing why
because if you had this this proof goes
through regardless of whether the theory
is consistent or not
so it's too clever by half
but it was good enough for von neumann
who thought that no formalized the
current orthodoxy no formalized system
can prove its own consistency that's
what you see in all the encyclopedias
and all the textbooks
okay but we prevented we prevented the
contradiction because i'm not proven
consistent is prevented because i'm
unprovable doesn't
exist and what this takes us
to is a discussion
about powerful theories can prove their
own consistency
but that proof in itself is not
convincing because the proof goes
through
even if the theory is inconsistent
[Laughter]
okay now the the people watching this
are going to be much younger and smarter
than i am
uh but just let me get it straight so
what are the things that people have
thought we can't do
um
system can prove its own consistency
no that was the that's the orthodoxy
in the end you're going to say that
there's still something we can't do
right
what's that the they're what the
incompleteness that's right
but now we're talking about consistency
don't confuse consistency with
yeah we have to not confuse consistency
with incompleteness
right okay and uh and just repeat for us
what completeness is
completeness is that there are true
propositions that are unprovable
okay now once on once i'm unprovable
bites the dust which it does we
have to come up with a different true
but unprovable proposition to show
incompleteness
and that we will do
okay so now
but we can have a more convincing proof
of consistency
by showing that there's a model in fact
a unique model
up to a unique isomorphism of your
axioms and that's another way of showing
consistency
that is convincing
so what this means is that contra
the current uh
dogma
which was followed by they thought that
existence of
i know approval shows it'll never be
possible acquire with mathematical means
so certainly the mathematics does not
contain contradictions
and we have a different approach namely
using models of showing it
okay so now let's go
and construct a true but unprovable
proposition
and we're going to do it via the great
alonzo church
with something that goes all the way
back to euclid
since euclid that the dog the
the orthodoxy is that you can get all
the theorems of a theory
by algorithmically enumerating them
starting with the axioms
and applying rules of inference
okay so that's going to turn out to be
our true but unprovable proposition
how does this work well
we're going to skip okay so we have the
the way this works is via something that
church thought up
and here we're making use of a very
famous technique that was thought up by
cantor called diagonalization
and cantor used it to show that you
cannot
the the that that that you cannot uh
put the the real numbers in one to one
correspondence with the natural numbers
right
that they are and the the real numbers
are uncountable
so using that same trick modified
slightly
church used it to show that if you
if your theory has can prove that my
theorems are innumerable
you can do diagonalization again it
against it and show that the theory
is contradictory so
church presented this proof in 1934
and his conclusion was that mathematical
logic is impossible
[Laughter]
that's what he wrote down right he could
not this this this argument is so
powerful like nobody's been able to
figure out how to get rid of
you could get away from cancer's
argument either it just stands there
right
attacked many times so he couldn't
figure out how to get around it so he
concluded the mathematical logic is
impossible
but he's still he's he he's
he's the chief editor of the journal of
symbolic logic he's at the head of his
field right
he proves things before
turin does okay
he's at the apex of his field so what do
you do
you just you publish your paper and
quietly forget it same
we'll fix this later
and so that's what happened until we
came along and said well
look this is a serious matter for us
right we've got these cyber attackers
coming for our throat we can't let this
stand
right we cannot it's impossible
so what we do is
we have to prevent it then we prevent it
using strong
types so we put orders on things
and we conclude
that the proposition that theorems of
order i
okay that all theorems of order i are
provable
for a theory that is the true but
unprovable proposition
because we can use church's argument to
show that it's not provable
okay but we can use model theory to show
that it's true
so that's how we finally succeed in this
long
quest to actually formally prove
incompleteness it's been a long journey
right
and at the time when turret when
when girdle was working on it right it
was strongly suspected
incompleteness was strongly suspected
okay by many people
but people didn't know how to prove it
and for a long time it was thought that
that girdle had succeeded in proving it
but we now know that that is not
the case he did not prove incompleteness
for foundations because i'm unprovable
it cannot be allowed to exist
so that is how we finally arrived at a
true
but unprovable proposition and by the
way
girdle played a dirty trick on von
neumann
it's just only been discovered in the
last couple of years
goodwill claimed he had a proof that he
didn't have
and when when when von neumann came up
with with the idea for it
girdle claimed he had a proof in order
to fend off von neumann
then then girdle hurley set to work
found the proof and published it and
claimed it is
at his as his own and this is all laid
out by an article by bon plato
a very good article which is in the
references
to the article that we have put a link
to at the beginning
of the colloquium
so that's our adventure okay so just a
quick review
so we've got types and as i understand
the basic idea
is if you've got a property of something
then the property
is of a higher type than the something
it's a property of
all right well yeah whenever you write
we're doing recursive definitions when
you do a recursive definition
right right the the propositional
variables
okay are one or go up one level
and the predicates go up one level we're
dealing with recursive definitions
because that's the
thing on which computation on which
mathematics
and computer science is based is the
recursive
okay but now you're not just about types
you're talking about
strong types and that brings in orders
am i correct
oh yeah strong types bring in orders
because every proposition has an order
a proposition is a type it's
parameterized with its order
basically another a number so that's
right strong type is just
you got types and then you got the types
in order
right but not but but not all types have
orders and this was a mistake that
that russell made that brought down
principia mathematics
he thought n the type of natural numbers
he thought that had to have an order
and that is a disaster okay
it makes mathematics impossible and so
russell thought about this and he
thought about this and he finally he
invented a cluj called the ramified
theory of types
okay and the ramified theory of types is
for every
higher order type he hypothesized there
must be a pop
every higher order proposition there
must be a proposition of order one
that's logically equivalent
everybody thought that was a crock
yeah but but without it he couldn't
really get identity straight as i
remember because
you know if a's identity would b they've
got to share all properties
that's right that doesn't quite make
sense but if you say they have to share
all first order properties given the
axiom of reducibility or whatever it is
that'll work fine and that that is
that is a clue that is a clue that's
right
yep okay
okay so
so we're in the business of preventing
successful cyber attacks
in particular attacks against
foundations attacks based on i'm
unprovable which must not exist
i'm not probably consistent which must
not exist
my theorems are innumerable which must
not exist now these are different in
kind
from the current existing attacks in the
wild but if you believe wikipedia the
stanford encyclopedia in the textbooks
that the attacks will succeed
because we're moving into a regime
in which we have things like siri
and things like alexa
and etc similar ones uh
by all these guys
here we go all these guys
cortana their os
by baidu google home siri and tay tay is
a good one
tay is the famous bot that microsoft
introduced it was a learning bot
so it was taking up all the things that
were being told to it so it could learn
right
learning's a good thing and pretty soon
it was a
raving anti-semitic
racist misogynist monster
and now microsoft had to take it down
so this you see this is the realm into
which we're moving
now and once you move into that realm
then uh you're up against i'm unprovable
i'm not probably consistent and my
theorems are innumerable
and first order logic is incredibly
vulnerable to these kinds of attacks
because it has no types
and we really want to prevent some
successful attacks as opposed to trying
to mitigating failures
and that's the business we're in now
mitigating failures
our current system is swiss cheese it's
not based on strong types it's not based
on
on microprocessors that have strong
types
and it's going to take
real work to get there so
there's something called project liftoff
that some of us in the silicon valley
are working on
and it is an apollo scale project
to get us out of this project liftoff in
the next decade can prevent successful
cyber attacks
against current systems
but it's going to take work
somebody some governments some great
power
is going to have to put up a lot of
money and 10 years of work to get there
but when they do so they will become
invulnerable
to cyber attacks from the other great
powers
so there's a famous case from world war
ii where germany worked
on everything except for the one thing
that mattered
they had these amazing
rockets built by von braun using slave
labor which were amazing weapons
they had messerschmitt jets which were
better than anything the allies
could run circles around the allied
fighters
right which would be just amazing
but there was one thing that they didn't
do and that was to have a project that
to build the only thing that mattered
the only thing that could save them
and that was the atomic bomb
but it took a political decision at the
highest level of the united states
government
to to to to place a bet of that size
that was one hell of a humongous bet
right
and you can't be certain i mean how do
you how do you know to believe
x y and z right well the fbi looked at
oppenheimer and said hey look
this guy j robert oppenheimer
his mistress is a member of the
communist party
right his brother is a member of the
communist party right
his wife is an alcoholic
you're going to put him in charge of the
project with all these you know
bet our future on him and grove
said yes groves news his man
j robert oppenheimer was a patriot
now he had people working for him who
were russian spies that he didn't know
about
but that was the fbi's job to find them
out right
but j robert oppenheimer was a patriot
and he ran a successful project
okay which if germany hadn't succeeded
if we hadn't if we hadn't been
successful in normandy et cetera et
cetera
it would have obliterated german cities
as it did a couple of japanese
cities which was a huge tragedy
so that's the kind of decision making
that we're up against here and and it's
not part of the
the american culture to go for this kind
of a big
project it doesn't seem to be built into
the dna
now roosevelt could do it and
jfk could do it for apollo
the question is can we do it
what do you think john well
uh i think that uh
cans pretty broad word i think we can do
it
it'll require not just money and a
leader that can get the money uh
uh to to the people to do it but
it will also require the people to
require a generation of electrical
engineers and computer scientists
uh who can kind of uh forget what
they're taught in their logic classes at
present and say
hewitt's got a good idea let's develop
that
actors theory and and and that's
you guy you i shouldn't say you folk
uh so i hope you do it and
finally let me close with what one
thought um
vladimir putin had a different strategy
15 years ago or 20 years ago
and i explore that strategy
in a youtube video which you can find by
going to
youtube and searching for typewriters
comma
john perry and uh i hope it
doesn't persuade you not to read
carl's article uh which now that you
heard this lecture will
will be much easier to understand
thank you john two things one is
that john is the founder one of the
founders of csoi
which is an absolutely terrific project
at stanford it's been going on for many
years
and it has produced some remarkable
works on logic
uh by him and some of his colleagues and
also
the world's best natural language parser
part
parser by uh dan flickinger and his
colleagues
the world champion the one on which
we'll have to build if we want to be
successful
in our adventures in cyberspace right
now this parser is being used for guess
what
it's being used for teaching english to
the chinese
[Laughter]
so so so we what we need to do is
bootstrap csli at stanford and at other
universities because we still have
the best university system for producing
the people that are going to
have to be required to do project
liftoff
at stanford at berkeley
at university of washington at carnegie
at mit at harvard
at princeton etc that
is the system that can produce the
people to do
project liftoff
and the other funny thing is respect to
putin is putin knew that the nsa was
getting the goods on him right
time after time so he actually just he
actually for a while convert i don't
know what he's doing anymore
to mechanical typewriters figuring that
was the hardest thing
for the nsa to bug right so he was he
was doing this top secret stuff that way
[Laughter]
but that's not the future the future is
is is is
is defense and defense can win here
any final words john no
uh no just uh uh enjoyed working with
you
uh not in really adding anything to your
lecture but in helping you uh um
keep it out of the weeds to a certain
extent and
uh it's been fun and so thanks for
letting me be a part of it you're very
welcome we we're glad to have you here
and i hope we're still friends
[Laughter]
so carl and john i want to thank thank
you as well i think that
the interactive format really
is one of the better ways to present
this kind of information
and uh it would i think uh
very very well and i think uh even
though i've been
tracking what carl's been up to for
quite a while i think i learned
something
so thank you to you both and um
i guess i'll uh i'll drop us off the
recording
bracket now and we'll this will be on to
uh youtube in a fairly short order
thanks very much